we have an exclusive clip from this
Sunday's episode that's upcoming
anything we need to know for this clip
you know I think there's some cool stuff
going on in this clip i think it's i
think it's Glenn asserting himself the
character played by Steven Yeun who's
been on the show Greg on the show and
he's a terrific let's take a look at
this clip from Walking Dead you stash
these at the loading dock alright that's
more off on the catwalk if anyone gets
pinned down we need to make sure that
they have plenty of ammo I'll go work on
the cage outside what we should be doing
is loading some of this firepower in a
truck and paying a visit to the governor
we know where he is right now he's
suggesting that we just go in and kill
him yeah I am we told Rick and Daryl
that we'd stay put
I've changed my mind sweetheart and on
the sidelines with my brother out there
and sitting right with me
[Applause]